which country produces the most
beautiful women it's a matter of global
importance what i think is i think the
most beautiful women are produced in la
porte texas but outside of that if you
want to have the discussion
that's where your
laporte high school yes so what what do
you think i got to tell you man i think
it's absolutely neck and neck between
venezuela and colombia man like it's i
and you know what i i think uh thanks to
the wonders of cops venezuela on
colombia thanks to the wonders of
communism colombia might have pulled
ahead in the last 10 years because you
know
eating dogs are bad luck now here's the
thing both of you guys have some
experience you played baseball and you
traveled which means you were i can
already see you being like
you know a guy that got around and adam
you know your mom and i had a great
conversation yesterday okay yeah you
know she was encouraging me to
uh uh you know like have some positive
influence on you i promise you behind
closed doors you're an incredible rabbi
you just don't want to tell her you're a
rabbi
what do you think most beautiful woman
in the world well i think there's two
ways we can go here we go by the way
everybody's listening what do you think
i'm actually curious we're looking at
the comments i think
uh yeah i would love to hear the
comments number one somebody said a
syrian that's actually not better
syrians make beautiful there's two ways
to look at this i think
yeah i'm not going to give you the
outside beauty inner beauty i'm just
going to give you you know there is no
such thing as inner beauty because it
was a beauty if there was an outside
beauty when you speak like that you're
looking for a wife so wait he's
transitioning respect here's the deal
inner beauty you don't care about inner
beauty until there's a lot of beauty
with your
small head gerard
you just go with your eyes only eyes
only and maybe you're right with
columbus you're about to go in the right
direction
but go ahead i'm a huge fan of banter
okay banter yeah so i like american
women i like banter like we're talking
about subject ding ding ding ding ding
we got it i've been i've been out with
adam a bunch and it's it's incredible
that the women who must have the most uh
incredible banter all are about five
foot six and a hundred and fifteen
pounds
this the the the amount of the amount of
gravity you got
right there buddy
the amount of banter maybe that's 23
years
maybe that's why you've only seen me out
with them once or twice because the
banter wasn't that good and we had to
move on okay but i've heard so you're
saying american i love american well
what what prompted this is is my buddy
jason fox who was here over the weekend
was telling me that the best guy by the
way good dude man yeah the best place
he'd ever been in the world he said was
croatia and that was the second time i'd
ever heard that my buddy chris john
who's albanian how many countries have
you been to how many countries have you
been to i've been to i've been to canada
mexico you know you've never been
nowhere if you start off with i've been
to canada like i've only been i've only
been oh no colombia i've been and that's
it so i've only been in north america
central america and uh
the caribbean and and the the north of
south america so i not left the western
hemisphere no i'd love to go to i was
supposed to go to europe uh last year
but i got two years ago but i got i got
i had other plans unfortunately usually
irish women are not in your top so you
so you irish are known for being tough
and and being uh smart and being uh
funny and good at banter i got
argentina colombia philippines sweden or
lebanon
russia russia you got to make an
argument for russia
uh albania assyrians uh brazil
uh chicago another assyrian chicago
actually low-key beautiful women by the
way three people said assyrian so at
this point the poll is over with it
i think the most beautiful women are
uh let me do the math here 25 assyrian
25 armenian father born and raised in
iran mom white from texas 80 percent
british i think that's the best
combination her name is senna i was
going to say yeah
santa brooklyn she is turning into a
beautiful girl senna has some
personalities
your facebook lives with her hilarious
so what car
what color pink
so you want to buy pink rainbow
so who's going to buy it for you you
why i don't have any money
so cute save that money senate
russian by the way i know we're gonna
move on i feel like russian you're
either like a five foot eleven
supermodel or you're like a babushka
grandma they don't speak the the gupta
but they're great at banter so who cares
for you because you like bands you give
me the five foot eleven supermodel
that's got a good banter
by the way if you get the 511 supermodel
who's strong that can put you in your
place it may be an interesting
relationship right there all of a sudden
you see can you imagine adam starts
dating a girl every time you go out
adam's very quiet you go to dinner come
on i'm not saying anything she says say
say something say something adam's just
quiet hi how are you dear can i get you
something
i can see that happening i told you not
to talk yeah yeah why tell you sorry boy
you've been to a lot of different
countries yeah you've been to how many
20 plus i don't know
i've been i've been out all over europe
i've been in australia i've been to
south america yeah i've been all over
united states beauty not not for
relationship just pure looks what was
what was the most beautiful woman you
saw where
just on look i would say i was in
mykonos greece and that's pretty
ridiculous over there greece
yeah yeah yeah i think croatia is at the
top of the line i got an idea gerard and
i hit the scene we go all over europe we
do some man on the street
if we don't talk about the the uh i will
say this the continent of the 48 here we
go i've been to 43 into the continental
48. you've been to 43 continents yeah no
no 43 of the continent i've been to 43
continents three planets all of it on
mushrooms by the way but the uh the
best looking women i've seen in america
is south florida by far i think it's
pretty
and then california's going to come at
me hard on this one but i think south
florida is i lived in california 24
years i'm still going to say south well
depends on your test taste south uh
florida is legit they can't compete
we're doing okay down here i think you
are yeah but everyone up in new york
who's watching this your wife comes stay
in new york you want no part of this
stay in new york charles barkley would
say the best looking woman are out of
san antonio
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]